but we can get some further reaction now
from the mayor of Greater Manchester
Andy Burnham thanks for being on the
program a bit of a different interview
to the one we're expecting what is your
reaction uh to the sucking of Nadim
zahawi
well my kind of first reaction uh Sophia
is that the government really must learn
lessons from this situation this
um conclusion has felt inevitable hasn't
it for a long time and yet it's been
allowed to dominate pretty much most of
January when there is probably the worst
crisis in the National Health Service
that I can remember and also we've got
collapsing public transport around the
country people can't get to work and
attention should have been on those
issues absolutely those issues because
they're critical for millions of people
and yet the airwaves have been taken up
with this and the government has to
learn a lesson from this this should
have been dealt with much more quickly
um uh Mr zahar we should have been asked
to step aside uh even from his role
before the conclusions of this inquiry
because it shouldn't have been allowed
to dominate in this way and as we can
see it's not just this now there are
other investigations uh ongoing as well
so they must learn lessons from this and
get government Focus where it needs to
be on the very serious situation that
there is out there for millions of
people struggling with the cost of
living crisis ambulances queuing outside
of hospitals train timetables that are
just non-existent in large parts of the
country those are the things that the
British public urgently need their
government to focus on
there's been a lot of pressure on Rishi
sunak over this not least because his
first speech as prime minister he
pledged to lead a government of
Integrity professionalism and
accountability
um is there an argument that by sacking
Nadine zahawi in this way as soon as he
got the conclusions of the report not
allowing him at the right to resign
himself he is showing a strength on the
issue
well Knox I think the mistake that he
made I've already pointed to which is he
should have asked Mr zahari temporarily
to step aside from his role uh while
this investigation was going on so that
uh it wouldn't dominate uh in the way
that it that it has done and that was
not uh done and that's why I say the
government does need to uh to look at
the way it's handled this and do things
very differently it's become a bit of a
Hallmark of this government hasn't it
where we've had uh you know the bullying
allegations against ministers just
rumbling away all of the time and the
problem with that is it takes sort of
much needed oxygen away from the issues
that need to be that need to be debated
and this is one of the things that
frustrates people about Westminster it
will obsess on something like this but
it will largely ignore the fact that the
the timetable on the main Railway line
in this country that links the main
cities of this country collapsed
yesterday thousands and thousands of
people had their weekend plans literally
at torn uh by Avanti West Coast and yet
where is that who is debating that who
is speaking up for those people in the
media well I'm trying to I came on today
to try and do that for them and yet
we're talking about this you know a kind
of a Westminster
um concocted uh mess basically which
they should have dealt with much much
earlier and and that I think brings out
what's a lot of what's wrong with this
country at the moment and a lot of what
is really frustrating people people are
genuinely struggling to get to work to
live their lives to pay the bills and
they don't see that fully reflected in
what's going on in Westminster and what
is then debated in the media I can feel
your frustration at not being able to
talk enough in this interview about
trains buses and you know the area that
you represent you'll forgive me because
this is quite a big breaking story that
we weren't expecting
but shouldn't you go with that because
is it right that we obsess on this the
prime minister's made his decision he
made it too late but should we now go on
to what's going on in the National
Health Service and on the railways I
don't know I mean I'm just I I think
this is the problem and we repeatedly
get ourselves into these uh Westminster
dramas that that actually take attention
away from the things that most people
are really really frustrated about so
would you like then a line to be drawn
under this now for labor to stop you
know attacking the Prime Minister uh for
it for people to say look you know the
decisions we made let's move on let's
talk about other things
no I think you should do two other
things today I think it should uh deal
with the Dominic Rob situation in the
way that I've I've described
um and that isn't going my investigation
is ongoing it's so important to hear
everyone who wants to give evidence
right exactly but where ministers are
subject to Serious investigations like
that I think they should temporarily
step aside from their roles the Boris
Johnson situation uh needs uh to be
dealt with questions need clearing up
but by failing to do that they then
Dominate and that's the issue that I'm
kind of raising I guess here you know
from our perspective we're trying to
keep public transport going we're trying
to support colleagues in the NHS you
know we're trying to resolve some of the
disputes out there uh in the in the fire
service and yet those things are much
bigger than this but they are going uh
really sometimes unreported I often see
people saying that on social media who
is speaking about the fact that I can't
get a train to London today and my life
has been completely turned upside upside
down and I don't know I just think we're
living in very strange times where the
disconnect between what's going on in
Westminster and the rest of the country
is getting bigger and bigger people are
getting more and more frustrated about
it and the government really needs to
hear that and it needs to sort of deal
quickly with these things and put them
to one side and get the focus back on
where it's uh where it should be I'd
love to know how much time has been
taken up in in Downing Street and uh
Whitehall this week dealing with this
situation and I bet they've spent more
time on this than they have on on the
other things I've mentioned
you talked a lot about trains I would
like to talk to you about strikes as
well while we have you and of course
teachers are walking out on rolling
strikes from next week do you support
them
I I do support people who have struggled
to pay their bills you know you can't
say it's wrong for someone who's had
real terms pay cuts for years and then
finds themselves in the cost of living
crisis to try and protect themselves
what I would say is it should never come
to this what happened to getting around
the negotiating table and sorting things
out that's how things used to be done
and it's how things should be done
always in these situations it's never
the case that one side should get
everything that they want and the other
side's completely wrong there's always a
negotiation to be had and what I've
observed at the moment there's a sort of
culture of letting issues rumble on and
playing the politics of the situation
trying to turn the public against the
nurses or against the teachers or
against the paramedics and the
firefighters rather than actually
sitting down and solving things you know
these problems on the railways so they
are entirely fixable they could be fixed
uh tomorrow and yet they are allowed
just to rumble on and rumble on and
that's what I mean about government
really starting to get a grip I'm
focusing on things that matter to people
and not allowing just these multiple
disputes to to continue you can't blame
people who've had real terms pay cuts
for years who then find themselves in
the cost of living because you can't
just expect them to keep going to work
and sit there as their problems at home
Mount up how can they kind of give all
of their attention to our kids in the
classroom if they're worried about
what's going on with with their rent and
and their ability to to keep their home
I mean it's just basic isn't it you've
got to help people in a time like this
you've got to talk to people and I would
I as a minister I'm not just saying this
sort of like you know so I wouldn't do
it myself I do do it myself I am talking
to our firefighters we are trying to
resolve issues here you know we used to
have a culture of that in this country
didn't we used to be called beer and
sandwiches and smoke-filled rooms and
all that what's happened to fixing
things negotiating and getting the
country functioning again it seems
somehow that's out of fashion and it
really shouldn't be
okay thanks so much for being on the
program uh Mr Burnham I promise that we
would invite you all again sometime soon
to talk about some of the issues I know
we were planning on doing this morning
buses next time yeah we will do more
questions on trains and buses that's a
promise Andy Burnham thank you very much
for indeed